bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ma chaîne youtube vous l'avez peut
être constaté sur les réseaux sociaux
chaque jour en cette période de
confinement je partage avec vous un
nouveau savoir en vous faisant profiter
de mon petit bout de jardin quand il
fait beau ou de mon atelier
une capsule de des conflits nés en
quelque sorte chez jungle
suite à vos nombreuses sollicitations
j'ai décidé de franchir le pas et de
créer ma propre chaîne youtube alors
pour le moment vous allez y retrouver
ses capsules quotidiennes mais dès que
le confinement sera terminé eh bien vous
pourrez découvrir d'autres formes âgées
parlerait de mes émissions de mes livres
des lieux insolites que je découvre pour
vous abonner il suffit de cliquer encore
une fois merci beaucoup pour tous vos
messages généreux et encourageant à très
bientôt et surtout n'oubliez pas nous
sommes confinés
mais on reste en lien